So let's let me show you how we can apply.
To Shear to this line, okay.
That's our Vector. I'm going to create here a transformation
matrix. So this is our vector.
and
if I type it out here we will see.
Okay, I this is I don't want 100
points. If you remember I said we can make it only two points. So let me modify this
code.
I thought I deleted this little.
delete this
delete that.
one more time
once more click on all
yeah.
so
this is x sub 1 x sub 2.
y sub 1 y sub 2
so
X goes from x sub 1
X sub 2 they're all on the same place, but for
why we go from y sub 1 to Y
sub 2 that's that's eight.
So
I'm going to multiply this Matrix.
With a transformation matrix, so I'm going to go look at
my code here and let's call this shear.
and this will be a 2 by 2
just like
in this presentation from I think
this is UC Urban.
Make sure to give them credit.
Where was this year
this year?
That's the one.
So I want to go NP dot array.
and if you remember from the LED composition session
we said that this is an identity Matrix.
This says key Pro 1 as is.
and this one says keep row two assets if I had done one
here, then we would be
multiplying or rather adding Row 1 to
R2
if I do this and I multiply
V1 it's called a vector but it's really a matrix right because
x sub 1 except to Y sub 1 y sub 2 but anyway,
if I multiply these two together if I do if I use the mat.
Multiply methods. So this is my
original vector.
I'm going to say V1.
V1
I think when you apply transformation user fee.
I can't use apostrophe here. So I'm just going to use.
transform
and this will be NP mode multiply.
So the transformation matrix must come first. So Shear times
V sub 1
and then I'm going to draw.
the vector after I have
applied some geometric transformation
So the original one stay let's make the original one black.
C equals black
and the transformation will be red.
C equals red
now I just complaining because
yeah, because this has to be
A list this has to be honest.
Let's try that again. One, two three.
Okay, and yeah, so obviously the red
is drawn over the black one because this is still an identity Matrix.
If I want to share it if I want to make it slanted left
or right I have to change.
this element
So let me try to and of
course we have to keep in mind our access goes and increments
of what is this 2.5?
So if I wanted to go 2.5, I'm just gonna make it 2.5. Let's
see what that does.
Okay, that's a lot. Let me make it.
less than that 0 Maybe
1.25
Oh, that's still too much.
Let's make it.
about this
Okay, I mean, it's still applying Shear, but I know I don't want it to
be this extreme.
And of course we can go the negative Direction.
Okay.
Let me go whatever as much smarter number.
How about
what is this?
fine
Yeah.
So imagine you have an object.
Like in the video game and you want to make sure it has
a shadow I can use a sheer effect.
Now what if we want to create a plane our plane if
you let me borrow this code again?
Paste it here.
And a matrix is a
set of vectors instead of
row vectors.
So let's say we have the following.
We create a matrix m.
Initially, you will be an empty list.
And now let's say we want to give this Matrix.
10 rows
it will be of
our row of
10 10 rows of vectors
All of them eight which each row
would be a vector which and will be 8.
points
It's like will be 8.
And I'm going to put each row inside the Matrix. So if I run
this.
Okay. Oh, no, we're not gonna see it just yet. But maybe this is a
if I type an m dot shape.
Okay, so we have 10 rows.
Two by two well, but this is a this is a list of two dimensions.
This is X an X and Y.
Okay.
I'll show you what I mean in a second now if I plot this
Matrix.
So I'm going to go.
here
alright
Let's make this.
Horror or let's make this V.
For each V in them for each Vector inside the
Matrix I run this.
So you can see here we have ourselves.
a plane
Okay.
Now if you wanted to look like a plane like we see here.
I can close it. I can close the displacement. I want
to call if I close this placement here.
I can make them move in a fractions right now. They're
moving in increments of I think in one increments
of one.
but if I make this, you know one tenth
you can see now they're
it's starting to look like a rectangle.
Let me make it a little.
increase in displacement and you can see
let me go from five to 100.
to increase the width
Okay, maybe maybe the increased displacement
and more. Let's go 150.
Yeah.
so now if I apply to this like before
so I'm gonna go here.
gonna copy paste this
and multiply this I'm going to go M sub.
transform
multiply the shear matrix by the original
Matrix
I run this now.
So that's the original one. But if I say m transform
there we have now applied to the Matrix.
Okay.
So this linear transformation works for either the vector?
and the Matrix so after all Matrix is just
you can imagine as a sequence of vectors but not necessarily
because if you have four points you can we can use
the fill between method.
to draw